en este vídeo vamos a hablar más acerca
de la inflación y la deflación ya hemos
tocado este tema en otros vídeos pero
ahora vamos a hacerlo en el contexto de
quién se beneficia y quién sale
perjudicado sobre todo cuando la gente
presta dinero con interés fijo vamos a
preparar un pequeño escenario aquí
supongamos que esto es el día de hoy y
esto es dentro de un año hoy necesito
hacerme una limpieza dental que cuesta
100 pesos es una emergencia pero no
tengo dinero para hacérmela tú eres mi
amigo y me dices yo te presto los 100
pesos pero voy a cobrarte intereses
desde mi punto de vista tú mi amigo me
estás prestando 100 pesos que te tengo
que devolver en un año
vas a cobrarme un interés del 10 por
ciento así que tengo que pagarte 110
pesos después de un año ahora pensemos
en términos de inflación imaginando
escenarios con distintos tipos de
inflación imaginemos un mundo en el que
no existe la inflación y supongamos que
el día de hoy es mi año base donde el
ipc es 100 imaginemos que el precio
actual de la canasta básica de bienes en
nuestro país es de 100 pesos esto nos
ayudará a visualizar las cosas con un
poco más de claridad como dijimos que no
tenemos inflación en un año el ipc el
precio de la canasta de bienes es
todavía 100 pesos así que en términos
reales podrías comprar 10% más con 110
pesos de lo que podrías haber comprado
con esos 100 pesos entonces realmente
estarías obteniendo una ganancia del 10%
en próximos vídeos hablaremos más acerca
de los términos reales y nominales ahora
imaginemos un escenario en el que hay un
poco de inflación una cantidad razonable
el ipc de nuestro año base es 100 y
después de un año tenemos una inflación
del 2% entonces nuestro índice de
precios al consumidor será 102 la
canasta de bienes costaba 100 pesos en
el primer año y 102 pesos un año después
como ya mencionamos hay que tomar en
cuenta que este no va a ser siempre el
caso de hecho en la mayoría de los
países realmente no puedes comprar una
canasta de bienes por 100 pesos por lo
general el 100 es solo un indicador que
nos ayuda a visualizar mejor las cosas
pero en el mundo de nuestro ejemplo con
los 110 pesos que yo te pagué vas a
poder comprar más que una canasta de
bienes no el 10% pero sí aproximadamente
el 8% más ahora imaginemos un escenario
donde tenemos una inflación realmente
extrema el ipc de nuestro periodo base
es 100 pero en esta situación tenemos
una inflación extrema donde el precio va
a aumentar más del doble y el ipc va a
llegar a 220 un año después
esto es realmente interesante porque en
este momento del presente la cantidad de
dinero que me estás prestando es
equivalente a la canasta de bienes de
hecho aquí ya podría comprar la canasta
de bienes mientras que en un año con lo
que te estoy pagando solo podrías
comprar la mitad de la canasta de bienes
aunque en términos nominales
aparentemente estás obteniendo el 10% de
dinero con esos 110 pesos solo puedes
comprar la mitad de lo que hubieras
podido comprar hace un año con 100 pesos
entonces en este caso aunque parece que
estás obteniendo el 10% de ganancia
nominal tu ganancia real es pésima
porque es negativa es menos 50% con lo
que te estoy pagando solo puedes comprar
la mitad de lo que hubieras podido
comprar con el dinero que me prestas te
originalmente la tendencia general en
estos casos es que cuando estás en un
entorno inflacionario sobre todo cuando
la inflación es mayor de lo que se
esperaba con frecuencia la tasa de
interés absorberá cierta inflación la
gente espera un poco de inflación cuando
utiliza la tasa de interés
y aquí podemos ver que me prestas de una
cantidad con la que hubieras podido
comprar la canasta de bienes porque el
día de hoy la canasta de bienes cuesta
100 pesos pero entre más inflación haya
con lo que te estoy pagando solo vas a
poder comprar la mitad de la canasta de
bienes incluso podemos imaginar que con
los 100 pesos que me prestas te en vez
de hacerme la limpieza dental compro una
canasta de bienes y luego un año después
la vendo por 220 pesos sólo tengo que
pagarte la mitad de esos 220 pesos así
que en esta situación no me hice la
limpieza dental pero obtuve una ganancia
superior a la inflación entonces la
inflación sobre todo cuando es mayor de
lo que se esperaba beneficia a los
prestatarios o los que piden prestado a
interés fijo vamos a escribirlo
beneficia a los prestatarios y repito a
interés fijo porque es posible que tu
tasa de interés esté vinculada de alguna
manera a la inflación en cuyo caso no te
beneficiaría tanto
y perjudica a los prestamistas
que dieron préstamos a interés fijo
ahora bien como podrás imaginar la
deflación va a ser lo contrario para
dejar esto muy claro vamos a imaginar un
escenario con una deflación realmente
extrema supongamos que nuestro ipc pasa
de 100 a 55 literalmente la misma
canasta de bienes que hoy cuesta 100
pesos dentro de un año va a costar 55 me
estás prestando el equivalente a una
canasta de bienes y voy a pagarte dos
canastas de bienes dentro de un año con
110 pesos podrás comprar dos canastas de
bienes entonces en este escenario
deflacionario vamos a escribir la
deflación aunque nominalmente parece que
tú el prestamista estás obteniendo una
ganancia del 10% en realidad estás
obteniendo una ganancia del 100% porque
ahora con lo que te estoy pagando puedes
comprar el doble de lo que podías
comprar con lo que me prestas t entonces
la deflación perjudica a los
prestatarios o los que piden prestado a
interés fijo vamos a escribirlo
perjudica a los prestatarios
y beneficia a los prestamistas que
prestan a interés fijo
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo